hey everyone persia here and welcome to
the game pass show where we're gonna
help
you find out what's in what's out and
what deserves a little bit more clout
when it comes to all the games on xbox
game pass go ahead and leave a like and
subscribe and we've got
a lot of games to talk about so let's
just head on into it
[Music]
the list of games heading our way are
battlefield v
chris tales
[Music]
atomic crops
raji an ancient epic
[Music]
last stop
blinks the time sweeper
crimson skies high road to revenge
microsoft flight simulator
lethal league blaze
omno
[Music]
project wingman
[Music]
and the ascent
as far as what's leaving us on july 31st
the list
is much smaller so no worries
you don't want to let go of any games
however the ones that are leaving
are it lurks below the tourist
and under mine as far as what i've been
playing on xbox game pass this week
and pretty much every week since i found
out it was on game pass
is no man's sky it has got so much
content
a lot of new free updates have been
hitting the game
and there's doggos space doggos
anyone who knows me knows that if there
is an opportunity to get a dog in a game
one i pretty much probably already did
it
and two i've already immediately loved
the game and no man's sky is
definitely right in that group of games
that
i love
aside from space doggos you can also
build
and craft epic awesome bases you can
complete missions
and get cool cosmetics you can fly
around space with your friends and
see their cool ships and go read
derelicts there's
a lot of stuff and it just seems to keep
getting better and the fact that it's on
game pass
available for you to play for free
including the free updates
is actually really cool so make sure you
check it out if any of that
sounds interesting to you now for my
pick of the week on xbox game pass
well it's kind of obvious since i'm
pretty obsessed with tetris but tetris
effect connected is absolutely amazing
you can play solo chill out to the great
music the amazing visuals
and just drop blocks at your own pace or
you can stress out with your friends and
play multiplayer
against these epic and wild ai boss
battles
oh i got scared for a second
they have some crazy tricks and some
really cool abilities well cool for them
i'm sure
less coal for me when i have to play
against it but regardless
super fun to take it on with your
friends and just
cooperate and play together there's even
a portion where all three of your
screens
come together and you can drop blocks
together across the whole
stage and send epic damage to the boss
at the end of it
all right everyone that is a wrap on
your game pass show
for july 31st hope you enjoy the games
that are coming
to the platform and maybe taking
advantage of the games that are leaving
on top of trying either no man's sky or
tetris effect connected
if you do hit me up on twitter at persia
underscore xo and tell me how much you
loved or
hopefully you don't hate these games
because i might get offended
just kidding enjoy your games and we'll
see you next time bye